[Musique]
Alexandre Mati, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Oui. Alors
euh donc euh je suis de formation
scientifique. Euh voilà, j'ai fait euh
tu es bon en math, ça m'a amené à
l'école polytechnique depuis la banlieu
nord. Euh et euh
euh je suis sorti euh dans le gratin là,
le corps des mines, les premiers là,
s'appelle des Xmines, on va en parler
puisque c'est un peu le sujet. Euh et
puis euh après, j'ai une carrière dans
l'administration euh dans l'entreprise
et puis de nouveau dans l'administration
euh cabinet ministériel. Euh euh puis à
un moment, je me suis dit bon, j'arrête
de chercher des postes prestigieux. Là,
j'ai fait une thèse euh d'histoire des
sciences.
J'ai une habilitation à diriger des
recherches là euh sur le transhumanisme
et puis donc mes fonctions c'est à la
fois au fonctionnaires et parallèlement
chercheur à l'université Paris Cité
euh euh donc Paris à l'ancienne Paris
d'Hydro donc voilà et Ah oui aussi ouais
je j'ai toujours beaucoup travaillé sur
des sites publics de diffusion de la
connaissance là j'avais créé
science.gouvre.fr fr qui n'existe plus
mais je je crée une bibliothèque
numérique d'histoire des sciences et
j'ai une chaîne dans la web TV des
universités là Canalu pour la culture
générale voilà pour diffuser la culture
générale une chaîne d'histoire et de
science en gros voilà bon
bienvenue on est très content de vous
recevoir. On a intitulé ce soir le titre
de l'émission, c'est la faille des
élites.
La technocratie, vous avez écrit un
bouquin sur les technocrates et de cette
technocrature technocratie
qui bah qui calanche un petit peu quand
même, qui qui tout saute, qui qui cale
ou la question, je vais je vais poser la
question direct, je suis désolé comme
vous le savez, je me suis tapé 4 heures
d'embouteillage à cause d'un grave
accident sur l'autorout 6. Donc je suis
un peu un peu remonté et je suis un peu
chauffé à blanc.
On voit bien que le pays part à vololo
en terme d'investissement,
d'anticipation, que ce soit à l'hôpital,
les autoroutes, le système énergétique,
l'anticipation de l'inflation, de la
guerre économique,
c'est quoi ? C'est notre nos élites, nos
nos pointes de diamant. En fin de
compte, c'est quoi ? C'est pas les
couteaux les plus affutés du tir qui se
retrouve à faire les grandes écoles.
C'est un entre soi. Qu'est-ce que c'est
? C'est parce que quand on les regarde à
l'extérieur et quand on voit leurs
résultats,
c'est médiocre dans le meilleur des cas.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? C'est une façon de
faire du pognon ? C'est une façon de pas
se rendre compte ? La conduite
introspective de nos élites, elle en est
où ? Est-ce qu'ils acceptent un petit
peu de se faire secouer, de se remettre
en question ? Je vous donne la parole.
Ouais. Alors,
tout ça c'est des des bons points.
Peut-être définir un peu le le les
grands corps dont je parle parce que
çaappelle les grands corps d'état quoi
finalement hein. Donc les à la sortie de
Polytechnique, le corps des mines, le
corps des ponts et chaussées et puis à
la sortie de l'ÉAL, l'inspection des
finances, le Conseil d'État et la Cour
des comptes quoi. Donc euh voilà,
pratiquement tous les présidents de la
République sont sont issus des corps de
l'ENAT là.
Euh président de la République actuelle
est est inspecteur des finances. Bon,
c'est des corps qui tiennent le pays. En
effet, l'inspection des finance, par
exemple, elle tient les banques
françaises euh depuis la libération et
même pendant sous l'occupation aussi.
D'ailleurs, sous l'occupation, c'était
un peu le le triomphe des technocrates.
On va appeler ça les technocrates
puisque le pouvoir politique était
discrédité en 1940. Je fais un peu
d'histoire aussi. Donc voilà. Euh
bon, pour revenir à au point actuel, euh
bon, il y a une certaine euh
oui euh sûreté de soi, une façon d'être
sûre de soi qui qui pose problème, je
pense et c'est critiqué pour le
président de la République actuelle. Je
je cite juste dans la troisème poche de
mon livre, je cite un truc. Quand
j'étais à l'assemblée du corps des
mines, c'est monsieur Macron qui était
ministre des finances à l'époque qui dit
il arrive, il rentre dans la salle,
c'est le corps des mines au qui auquel
il s'adressait et l'inspection des
finances, c'est cast habilité à la
direction des grands groupes.
Donc je sais pas, j'ai j'ai noté parce
que vraiment d'habitude je compte sur ma
mémoire mais là ça m'a tellement
estomaqué que j'ai vraiment noté tout de
suite.
J'ai le papier toujours et donc voilà,
c'est une façon de voir les choses.
C'est comme si on était des c'était des
castes qui sont seuls habilités à la
direction des grands groupes français.
Donc si on pense comme ça, c'est à la
fois c'était pour flatter son auditoire
mais c'était aussi pour parce qu'il le
pense profondément en fait. C'est c'est
un câblage en fait. Donc euh voilà
c'est c'est c'est cette certitude de soi
qui me paraît un petit peu Ouais.
Allez-y, allez-y.
Cette certitude. Pourquoi voir le mal ?
Parce que si c'est l'élite de l'élite,
le top gun de l'administration
qui vient s'occuper comme un bon père de
famille de nos grands groupes pour faire
rayonner la France. Si ça se passe bien,
c'est normal qu'on qu'on s'adresse
et puis et puis protéger nos grands
groupes avec des gens formés
correctement.
au renseignement pour éviter de se faire
écraser, instrumentaliser ou de les
faire chanter. C'est bien aussi qu'on
ait des gens opérationnels.
On en rencontre pas souvent d'ailleurs
des comme ça qui sont formés, évités de
se faire attraper ou ainsi de suite. Ou
sinon, on voit des hommes de paille de
la DGSE occupés de des places dans des
grands groupes. Je vois que ça vous fait
sourire.
Non non, je suis pas un spécialiste
d'intelligence économique moi, mais
c'est il est vrai que bah vous les
connaissez mieux que moi les affaires de
de d'Alstom. ou même les amendes BNP et
cetera, c'est des justement des grands
groupes euh qui a ont à leur tête des
des corpsards comme on dit. Mais bon,
vous avez raison, c'est vous qui
décrivez aussi un un panorama assez
négatif aussi. Donc je je
Pourquoi négatif ?
C'est vous qui avez le pays. Oui oui oui
oui tout à fait. Ouais ou
pourquoi pourquoi dire que c'est négatif
? C'est réaliste. Que ce soit positif ou
négatif,
le résultat est là.
Ouais ouais ouais. La dette française
c'est 3000 milliards. En terme de guerre
économique c'est turlu tututu chapeau
pointu,
bretel sans crème solaire, sans bob à la
plage et je me fais taner la peau. Ça
ressemble un petit peu à Michel Blanc
dans les bronzés, non ?
Oui. Oui. Bah je
et même la remise en question de ces
gens-là, c'est comment ? Oui. Alors la
derise en question il y en a très peu ça
mais je vous cite juste quelques ce que
j'appelle des bésinas industrielles et
financières quoi parce que faut les faut
les donner quand même. Donc
bon les amendes Alstom amendes BNP ça
c'est autre chose. Mais bah France
Télécom on a oublié on parle beaucoup de
Didier Lombard mais avant il y avait un
inspecteur des finances qui s'appelait
Michel Bon en 2002 par là c'est
attention pas de diffamation pas euh ça
ça été il y a pas il y a pas de
problème. a été lui-même a dit qu'il
avait fait il avait fait des erreurs
d'appréciation et donc ça il a dit à son
conseil d'administration de s documenter
tout ça. Donc il a perdu son il a arrêté
d'ailleurs et il fait d'autres choses
très bien en philanthropie et cetera,
tant mieux pour lui. Euh donc euh voilà
en même temps, il y a eu ses affaires
aussi de de dégringolade de Vivindi
avec un inspecteur des finances aussi
euh messier. Enfin bon voilà, je j' pas
cité des ribambelles de noms mais il y a
eu
Areva Alstom d'une certaine manière le
Crédit Lyonnais Péchinet je discutais
avec des jeunes qui étaient qui sont à
l'école des mines
euh civil des mines. C'est encore un
truc différent du corps des mines. Et
ben, ils connaissaient même pas le nom
de péchinet. Je rappelle que l'aluminium
a été créé en France. L'aluminium, c'est
Sainte-cler de ville, euh c'est euh euh
le four et et et ça vient des beau de
Provence, la la boxite près de d'Ex en
Provence, quoi. Et la France était très
forte en aluminium et Péchinet était
bradé. C'était un Xmin qui était à la
tête de ça. Euh voilà. Donc il y a la
désindustrialisation, elle est analyser
aussi en en perte de substance de nos
grands groupes, y compris dans la
sidérurgie aussi. On peut on peut
regarder ça de manière euh
voilà. Donc euh je peux couper encore.
Ouais. Ouais.
J'adore d'y discuter avec les politi les
polytechniciens parce qu'on peut bien
les secouer, il résistent bien la
pression. Euh c'est une forfaiture, une
forme de forfaiture ou c'est de
l'incompétence caractérisée ?
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire fortfaiture
pour les jeunes qui connaissent pas le
mot ? ou là, vous me demandez des
définitions de forfaiture, c'est
vraiment euh pour moi c'est euh
aller à l'encontre des objectifs, aller
à l'encontre complet des objectifs euh
qui vous ont été fixés euh par avec une
séance d'intérêt public, c'est-à-dire
des des intérêts publics nationaux et
cetera. C'est ça une forfaiture pour
moi. Donc je sais pas si on peut parler
de manière aussi
aussi forte de ça. Question.
Oui. Oui. Non. Donc
les boîtes en question, il y a il y a
c'est c'est multifactoriel. Ce que je
remarque, c'est que
il y a en effet jamais de remise en
question. Ça c'est tenez, regardez. Moi
je en 2011
on on
fêtait enfin bon voilà on honorait le
25e anniversaire de la mort de George
Bess Nickm mais alors c'était une autre
trampe à l'époque l'ancien patron de
Renault là qui avait été assassiné en 86
et et j'avais dit notre
notre monde des polytechniciens et des
grands corps peut pas se permettre de
faire l'économie de de ce que sont
devenues ces sociétés là aussi.
Qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé quoi euh à partir de bah de 2000
2010 ? Voilà donc une désindustriisation
massive et ça il y a jamais de remise en
question. Oui, c'est certain. Il y a
jamais de remise en question.
C'est toujours les mêmes qui président
les tables rondes dans les les cocktails
et les déjeuners alors qu'ils ont
gravement failli. Euh j'irai pas jusqu'à
forfaiture mais ils ont gravement
failli. Donc voilà. Et puis
euh euh dès que les élites se sentent
menacé, dès que ces élites se sentent
menacées, elles disent "Ah ben, on va
faire la diversification sociale". Vous
voyez, un peu à la bourdieu en fait. Et
et il y avait un il y a un sociologue
américain type remarquable he qui
s'appelle Esra Soulean qui en 78
on y reviendra
maintenant.
Ah d'accord. OK. Esra Soulean qui
vraiment avait une position pas
antibourdieu mais qui a une position
très complémentaire qui beaucoup plus
intéressante à mon avis. Voilà, c'est ça
beaucoup plus intéressante qui disait
quand les élites se sentent menacé et ça
arrivait déjà en 78, il y avait des des
éléments sur la table aussi, elle
euh elles en reviennent toujours à il
faut accélérer la diversification, faut
recruter dans d'autres milieux sociaux
que
nous. Et en fait, c'est une manière de
se poser, de dire de jamais se de
focaliser le débat sur le recrutement,
vers quel milieu sociau on recrute pour
éviter de le mettre le débat sur les
résultats, sur les euh quel est le quels
sont les azerreurs des élites et cetera.
Quelle est la légitimité, pourquoi les
recrutes comme ça ? Voilà, donc je sais
pas si je m'exprime correctement mais
c'est
disz quoi d'autre aussi ? Il les élites
n'acceptaient pas de se faire remettre
en question concernant leurs
compétences. leur utilité, leurs
résultats effectifs.
Ouais, voilà. Je vais prendre trois un
trépied, je vais prendre
le recrutement. Le premier c'est le
recrutement, la diversité sociale à
l'époque.
Technicien parce que un trépied, c'est
forcément trois hein.
Ouais. Ouais. Mais oui, mais quand même,
je le geste là, je sais. Ouais. Euh donc
je vais essayer de faire l'image
correcte. Le le premier point c'est le
recrutement, la diversité sociale. Avant
on parlait de fils d'ouvriers,
maintenant on va parler il y a plus
d'ouvriers donc on va parler de de
diversité et cetera. Bon ça c'est le
premier point. Le deuxième point c'est
la légitimité à savoir euh euh le
deuxième point c'est les résultats, à
savoir ce qu'on vient de dire. Est-ce
qu'on analyse les berésin ou pas ?
Est-ce que les voilà et le troisème
point c'est la légitimité au sens est-ce
que c'est légitime comme mode de
sélection ? C'est ça que pourquoi des
élites formées comme ça depuis le début
finalement bon la création de l'ENAT au
45 et cetera mais pourquoi ces ces ces
élites elles seules disent que quelles
sont elles-mêmes les élites ? Donc sur
les trois points, Bourdieu, il va
focaliser sur le premier point à savoir
le la la diversité, les le recrutement.
Et Souleiman, il dit "Mais c'est les
deux autres points qui sont beaucoup
plus importants parce que si on fait
venir un fils d'ouvrier, on va dire pour
être vite là, il va complètement adopter
la la le mantra des des autres si vous
voulez. Ça ça ça a pas tellement de
sens. la diversité, c'est important,
mais c'est beaucoup plus important de de
se demander quels sont les résultats
dans les entreprises, dans la politique
de ces gens-là, quoi, puisque c'est eux
qui tiennent aussi le pays
politiquement. Journalisme peut-être
moins, ça fait appel à des des
qualit enfin, je sais autre chose, mais
c'est surtout le monde de la grande
entreprise et le monde politique où il y
a ces membres de grand corps quoi.
Voilà. Et donc euh bon, il y a très peu
de de remise en question de disons de
voilà de euh
d'analyser euh si ça au contraire c'est
toujours glorifier la structure pour
qu'elle continue à exister finalement
une structure
a pour objectif de persévérer dans son
être et c'est un peu ça aussi qui se
passe
depuis longtemps maintenant. Donc les
résultats sont les suivants.
On est dans les meilleurs dans le
meilleur des cas, on est borgne ou
aveugle avec des grands groupes français
qui calanchent, mal protégé, mal géré,
attaqué de l'extérieur, attaquer de
l'intérieur fragmenté.
Par exemple, la SNCF, comment ça va en
ce moment ? Ça va bien la SNCFé,
pas privatisé. Le le l'énergie en
France, ça se passe bien. L'énergie en
France est compliqué.
SNCF c'est un bon exemple parce que
justement bah je vois vous aimez bien
l'histoire, on peut essayer d'en faire
un peu. C'était les polytechniciens
saint-simoniens qui parce que il y avait
vraiment une utopie saint-simonienne au
sens maintenant on entend Macron et
Saint-Simonien, c'est un peu n'importe
quoi mais bon cette utopie
saint-simonienne c'était on on la voit
dans des romans de d'un romancier du
terroir là Henry Vincenna qui parle des
enfin qui parle de sa jeunesse de
cheminot et voilà des polytechniciens
qui faisaient attention à la sécurité du
chemineau quoi. pas que la vitesse et
cetera et puis bah tout ça a perduré un
peu, on le voit, je cite des articles du
monde années 80 encore et puis et puis
il y a le big bang de l'arrivée d'un
conseiller d'État Enarc brillant qui
s'appelle monsieur Pépi à la tête de la
SNCF. Et c'est vraiment un changement
pour moi, c'est un changement complet de
voilà, il a ça va être le tout TGV, ça
va être la fin des ça va être le tout
rentabilité, la fin des des
enfin euh l'abaissement des trains
régionaux et cetera euh avec une
foultitude d'arcruter avec lui quoi.
J'en fais la liste là dans mon dans mon
livre. Ça va être un peu
la CNSV va devenir un réservoir des NAR
qui entre deux postes euh
passe là 3 ou 4 ans avec des des
salaires importants pour rebondir après
dans l'entreprise bien ils s'entourent
bien avec des gens qui connaissent
Oui. Surtout avec des gens qui
connaissent Est-ce qu'ils connaissent le
ferroviaire ? Est-ce que ça est-ce que
finalement ça ça tape pas sur le système
des autres qui sont dans la boîte quoi
aussi ? Est-ce que on gère une boîte
comme ça ? C'est vrai pour la CNCF,
c'est vrai pour autre chose ? pour
d'autres boîtes. C'est vrai pour
l'administration d'avoir ces gens qui en
permanence
disent je parle je parle d'une franche
des corps hein, disent que c'est eux les
meilleurs et que ça tape sur le système
des autres aussi quoi. Donc que ce soi
les autres membres de grand corps que ou
que ce soi les autres haut
fonctionnaires, les autres
fonctionnaires quoi. Donc il y a il y a
un aspect
Oui. Oui. une forme de de d'arrogance.
Ouais, je l'ai déjà dit de de sûreté de
soi quoi. Donc
l'administration
là en ce moment, on a un ministre de
l'économie s'appelle Bruno Leire
qui savait pas nous calculer la surface
d'un hectare.
Et il a fait les finances avant dans son
cursus. Il était quoi ? Il était
spécialisé en administration, prof
d'allemand. Qu'est-ce qu'il faisait
avant ?
Prof d'Allemand. Bah, il est normalien
ce que monsieur Macron a pas pu être. Et
et
la petite vanne quand même là, non,
il était narc et puis oui oui, il est
agrégé d'allemand enfin bon voilà. Donc
euh et
bar
et puis il a fait enfin il s'est laissé
porter dans le il était avec monsieur de
Ville Pain. C'est c'est surtout ça qu'il
a Et puis après il a il est passé du
côté de monsieur Macron. Oui, oui, c'est
c'est donc
vous avez confiance en lui ? Est-ce que
vous avez confiance
dans la capacité de la France à gérer
ses finances, à anticiper l'avenir ?
Qu'est-ce que vous, de votre poste, de
votre histoire, de votre, je vais pas
dire rang
percevez la situation de la France ?
Bon, c'est pas trop le mon domaine
d'expertise, c'est pas trop le thème de
mon livre, mais oui, oui. D'accord. OK.
Ouais, je me plier à l'exercice. Ouais.
Euh
ouais, je pense qu'il y a beaucoup enfin
la France est pas en situation
financière extraordinaire donc euh et
par ailleurs euh beaucoup d'argent qui
sont qui est investi dans des de manière
peu efficace je pense et je pense que
là-dessus euh en effet euh bah tout tout
ce qui est
ça tombe de on vit toujours sur la même
lancée des des dépenses
et puis c'est très difficile de
supprimer des structures par exemple
exemple là ça je vois mon expérience
administrative c'est sûr. Donc voilà
quoi. Je
il y a il y a
bah quand on regarde par exemple
l'industrie, on se dit que côté Suisse,
côté allemand, côté Italie du Nord même
on critique beaucoup l'Italie mais
l'Italie du Nord est restée très
industrielle. Donc
voilà, comment ça se fait qu'on ait
laissé des ps entiers de notre
industrie, voilà, quand on achète un
truc, parfois sur internet, ça m'arrive,
je vois ça vient d'Allemagne quoi, des
trucs industriels, des cornières pour
caler ses livres par exemple dans une
bibliothèque. Bon bah, ça vient
d'Allemagne, quoi. Ça vient pas de
Chine, ça vient d'Allemagne. Donc voilà,
il y a eu beaucoup de
Ouais, on peut dire de de enfin de
dépenses publiques pas toujours bien
placé quoi pour répondre à à votre
question.
C'est car in black.
Euh ouais, un petit peu. Enfin, il y a
longtemps que j'ai pas
un moment un moment il y a il y a on
pose la question mais pourquoi vous êtes
ici ? Alors l'autre répond parce qu'on
est les meilleurs, des meilleurs, des
meilleurs, des meilleurs. Un peu ce qui
se passe avec nos grands corps, notre
administration, c'est les meilleurs, des
meilleurs. Comment ça se fait qu'ils ont
besoin de cabinet de conseil payer une
fortune alors que eux c'est les
meilleurs, des meilleurs, des meilleurs
? C'est quoi ? parce que ils sont
complètement déconnectés de la réalité,
ils sont à l'ouest, je dirais, où ils
font travailler les copains, où ils ont
vraiment besoin de conséquen, ça se
passe.
Voilà, si si on veut décrire un peu
d'abord faut avant de parler des
cabinets de conseil, on en parlera. Faut
parler des cabinets ministériels aussi.
Ça c'est la c'est le NEC plus ultra.
Enfin, c'est voilà, faut être passé à 28
ans en cabinet ministériel quand on est
membre de Grand Cors quoi. Bon, moi j'y
suis allé à 40 ans, c'était très
intéressant au ministère de la recherche
avec Claudianuret après 10 ans dans
l'industrie. Donc c'était je veux dire,
j'avais je pouvais mettre en pratique
certains trucs que je j'avais appris là.
Là, c'est
on adore Claudie. Je suis désolé de le
dire mais on adore Claudine Moi aussi.
Euh et donc euh
voilà, donc euh là maintenant c'est euh
on passe euh un poste en province ou à
l'inspection des finances et puis on
rentre en cabinet ministériel assez tôt
et l'objectif c'est de partir le plus
tôt possible
en entreprise au bout de 2 ans de de
cabinet ministériel ou voire même on
peut citer deux hommes-femmes politiques
qui ont fait de la politique à partir
des cabinets ministériels. M PCR c'est
monsieur Vaquier là, mais je trouverai à
gauche aussi. Euh donc voilà, c'est
c'est pas que l'entreprise d'ailleurs le
le alimenter, c'est partir pour une
carrière politique à partir d'un cabinet
ministériel. Ça voilà la question que je
pose dans l'ouvrage, c'est pourquoi
notre pays accepte de parce que c'est
important les cabinets ministériel,
c'est devenu super important. Euh dans
l'administration, on dit euh qu'est-ce
que pense le CAB ? Il faut il faut
demander au CAB là-dessus. Cab, ça veut
dire cabinet, hein, vous l'avez compris.
Euh voilà donc et puis maintenant avec
la présidentialisation du régime, ça
devient aussi le le le cabinet de
l'Élysée euh et un petit peu le cabinet
de Matignon, quoi. Donc le
cabinet noir aussi, non ?
Ah oui, ça c'est oui oui oui. Et enfin
voilà, donc c'est important si on veut
comprendre ce système des grands corps
de comprendre que ça passe aussi par le
la clé de voûte. Voilà, la clé de voûte
du système des grands corps, c'est le
cabinet ministériel. C'est là que
le jeune se fera voir des grands
patrons,
des hommes politiques influents et
cetera
et continuera sa carrière. Or ces
cabinets ministériels édicent les
politiques publiques quand même. Donc
voilà. Moi je pose la question. Quelle
est la motivation de quelqu'un qui fait
2 ans en cabinet ministériel et qui
pense qu'à partir à a dictter des
à participer à décider sur les
politiques publiques si vous voulez.
C'est c'est c'est un vrai sujet ça quoi.
Donc euh pourquoi notre pays pourquoi la
France a-t-elle accepté de de enfin de
de se confier à à ces profils là hein
qui sont des profils qui ont pas
beaucoup d'expérience non plus, faut
bien dire ce qu'il est. et puis qui
veulent faire autre chose de pourquoi la
confier à ces profils là l'élaboration
des politiques publiques ? C'est un vrai
sujet çain. Donc voilà. Alors vous
disiez les cabinets de conseil ça c'est
c'est c'est autre chose mais c'est pas
autre chose en fait. C'est les mêmes qui
partent en cabinet de conseil quoi. Qui
partent au bout de 2 ans dans des
cabinets de conseil. Alors on entend
souvent parler de Minet. Euh
ben faut pas oublier aussi d'autres
cabinets qui étaient très
franco-français et puis qui ont explosé
aussi dans cette dans ces politiques
publiques dans ces Cap Gémini par
exemple. Cap Gémini, c'était au départ
c'était un gars Serge Kemp, c'était pas
n'importe qui. Je sais pas si vous voyez
qui c'est qui a créé à Grenoble Cap
Gémini. Et puis maintenant, c'est devenu
un truc qui est un un un une antichambre
des bah c'est là que vont pantoufler.
Pantoufler, ça veut dire partir dans le
privé tous ces jeunes qui sont en
cabinet ministériel. Euh et puis ben on
le voit, Mckins a participé à
l'élaboration des politiques
au moment de la crise sanitaire. Cap
Gini sur la la l'aménagement enfin les
sur les dépenses publiques. Enfin tout
est confié à ces cabinets. Donc euh en
effet oui, il y a il y a un petit comme
vous le dites une espèce de de gap entre
le fait "Ouais, on est les meilleurs,
mais on est les meilleurs mais on
aimerait mieux finalement être dans le
privé. Est-ce qu'on gagne plus ?" Et
puis
euh pour faire la même chose en fait.
Donc l'état délègue sa compétence quoi.
Ça c'est un peu embêtant quoi.
Votre interprétation c'est quoi ? de la
cupidité,
c'est l'envie de pouvoir de rayonner, de
monter, de monter, de monter. Où est-ce
qu'il est
l'envie
de protéger le pays, la nation, le
sacrifice
pour la notre nation ?
Est-ce que ça nous manque dans notre
administration ou est-ce que je vais
formuler la la question d'une façon un
peu plus triviale, c'est comme c'est
l'élite de l'élite de l'élite de l'élite
des meilleurs des meilleurs des
meilleurs, est-ce que il y a un racisme
de classe en disant
le bas peuple est con à bouffer du foin,
je vais faire un maximum de blé quand je
peux faire un maximum de blé quand je
suis encore jeune que je peux vivre à
dormir 3h par nuit à me faire insulter
dans tous les sens. Je vais faire un
maximum de blé et ensuite je vais me
frotter les mains dans le privé et je
vais repartir avec le carnet d'adresse
de la République ou c'est parce que ils
aiment l'argent, le pouvoir,
l'intérêt pour la patrie, il est où ? En
je sais pas, c'est un peu tout ce que
vous dites là. C'est-à-dire que
ouais, insensiblement des années 80 90
aux années actuelles, on est passé d'un
système où
on valorise on valorise beaucoup plus
les gens qui sont dans les entreprises
et qui gagnent de qui gagnent de
l'argent quoi. La valeur argent est
devenue euh mais ça moi je le vois dans
des discussions avec des camarades de
corps, on va dire du corps des mines par
exemple. euh la valeur argent est
devenue la valeur suprême. Euh euh
Oui, disons que euh vous connaissez
comme moi que les salaires en entreprise
et enfin le le l'éventail des salaires,
il est devenu euh enfin entre un grand
patron et et
un fonctionnaire.
Oui. Un fonctionnaire. Bah c'est ça.
Voilà. au sein d'un corps d'état par
exemple, il y en a qui qui restent au
fonctionnaire et un grand patron, on va
pas citer de nom mais euh ça c'est
devenu comme le reste des entreprises
des écarts très très importants quoi.
Les
gens réalisent moi je les connais à peu
près les écarts.
Donc un haut fonctionnaire même qui
gagne plus que le président de la
République qui a qui crèche à Berpuis un
nombre d'années, il est quoi ? Il est à
27000 € net.
Pas tant que ça. Non.
Il est à combien ? 15000 17000.
pouvez dire ça d'assez haut placé
avantages qui vont avec.
Oui oui oui oui d'accord. Ouais c'est
quoi ? C'est 2 millions 4 millions par
an.
Jeais pas vous dire comme ça c'est ça
tellement variable. En plus, il y a des
rémunérations variables. C'est euh
Oui, oui, c'est ça. Oui, bien sûr. Oui.
Puis des retraites de chapeau. Tiens, ça
c'est un truc qui a fait son apparition
qui est tout à fait choquant au moment
où on fait au moment où on fait la
réforme des retraites. C'est tout à fait
c'est tout à fait choquant de de de voir
ces histoires de retraite chapeau quoi.
et et sur certains profils que je décris
dans mon ouvrage, on voit au moment le
moment sur un profil puis on m'en a cité
un autre aujourd'hui,
le moment où se fait le
la bascule, c'est-à-dire que de
quelqu'un qui était soit au
fonctionnaire y compris après qui qui
rentre en entreprise et cetera,
on peut considérer qu'il continue sur sa
compétence, le bien public et cetera,
Mais dans les années 2010, il y a une
espèce de changement vraiment de de
passage à je veux gagner plus d'argent
quoi. Ça c'est très très net quoi. C'est
c'est entre 2005 et 2010 comme si la
crise financière de 2008 avait aiguisé
tous ses appétits.
Et
alors le service de l'État derrière, bah
écoutez
voilà le
moi ma thèse aussi c'est que ce qu'on
appelle moi j'ai mis du temps à accepter
ce vocable là, le néolibéralisme c'est
c'est c'est-à-dire le fait que l'État
organise la concurrence au départ le
néolibéralisme on peut considérer que
c'était l'État qui régule la la
concurrence qui fait attention que il y
ait pas de monopole et cetera et puis
après enfin maintenant c'est devenu plus
autre chose, c'est-à-dire c'est l'État
qui organise la concurrence dans des
domaines régaliens comme l'éducation,
comme la santé et cetera et et donc
l'énergie. Oui, raison. Euh donc euh euh
voilà, c'est c'est et les grands corps
sont vraiment à la base de cette ce
néolibéralisme parce que c'est justement
euh c'est c'est le rôle de l'État euh il
symbolise le rôle de l'État dans cette
libéralisation des services euh
l'État et l'Europe.
Oui. et l'Europe bien sûr sur l'Europe.
Ma thèse c'est aussi que le nos
grands corps qui soit dans la politique
ou la haute fonction publique appliquent
encore plus c'est des bons élèves. Donc
ils appliquent encore mieux les
directives européennes que d'autres pays
quoi à notre corps, à notre à notre
détriment je pense. C'estàd
ça paye mieux à l'Europe. C'est ça.
Oui parce que voilà il faut être
un échelon au-dessus en terme de pognon.
Ah non peut-être pas de pognon. Disons
que voilà, ils aiment bien être bons
élèves, donc euh voilà, ils vont bien
faire la la transposition des
directives, ça s'appelle. Alors que
d'autres él, ça veut dire bon petit
soldat, ça veut dire quoi ?
Ouais. Ouais. Ça veut dire ça veut dire
je sais pas, je trouve qu'en France, on
est souvent meilleurs élèves,
c'est-à-dire comme ils l'ont été
d'ailleurs toutes leur ce qu' les a
amené au poste où ils sont. Euh donc euh
oui oui, on fait de la transposition de
directives européennes.
Euh peut-être les autres pays comme
l'Allemagne et l'Italie euh ont un peu
plus freiné des cas de fer puis il y
avait des structures industrielles qui
leur ont permis de d'amortir ce choc de
de néolibéral finalement. Donc euh
voilà. Oui oui, je sais plus trop où on
en était là.
Donc les meilleurs des meilleurs des
meilleurs qui sont super bons élèves et
qu'en fin de compte on les connaît tous
ceux qui se mettent au premier rang en
général c'est pas les plus intelligents.
C'est ceux qui qui travaillent qui
travaillent qui travaillent qui
travaillent qui travaillent. Ça fait des
bons petits soldats mais en terme de
raisonnement c'est pas les couteaux les
plus affutés du tiroir.
Bah je vais vous citer un truc qui a
dans le bouquin d'un collègue Emrie.
Emer 12 ans. C'est il appelle ça c'est
la fabrique des ararques. Il dit pour
sortir dans les premiers d'abord l'ENAT
c'est fait que pour faire le classement
c'est-à-dire c'est fait que pour les 15
premiers les 50 autres on s'en fiche un
peu. seront administrateurs civil dans
différents ministères. Donc l'ENAT ne
sert qu'à distinguer les meilleurs
d'entre les meilleurs et même je pense
au sein de ces inspecteurs des finances
qui sera le Macron et cetera. Euh donc
euh et il dit euh pour sortir bien que
d'abord, il porte une critique très
sévère sur le il dit euh le toute
l'administration de l'ENA c'était c'est
fait pour ça quoi. Donc euh euh
pour s'occuper du classement des 15
meilleurs. Et il dit pour être dans les
15 meilleurs, les 15 mieux classés
ou les 10 mieux classés, il faut être à
la fois dans le moule.
C'est-à-dire cétait pas question un seul
moment de contester quoi que ce soit.
sur les les soit les politiques
publiques mais même contester quoi que
ce soit sur l'enseignement et cetera. À
la fois ça mais à la fois savoir taper
sur le petit copain au moment au bon
moment quoi. Et si vous voulez vous avez
c'est-à-dire voilà dans des dans des
cours des discussions et cetera, savoir
bang aligner l'autre
Ouais. Est-ce que c'est ça qu'on
recherche comme qualité finalement ?
Ouais, je je suis pas sûr quoi. C'est un
peu ce qui est et les ils sont
sélectionnés comme ça aussi les écoles
de commerce là, ils ont une espèce de
jury à trois là où bah les trois ils
sont notés en fonction de ce qu'ils
disent bien sûr, mais aussi la façon
dont ils peuvent renvoyer dans leur but
un petit camarade quoi. Est-ce queil
faut pas que les notes soient les mêmes
partout ? Donc voilà, je je c'est c'est
assez bien décrit dans ce bouquin sur la
ferme des Éars que voilà. Alors
maintenant, on fait des monsieur Macron
pour vous dire à quel point enfin bon je
moi ça rejoignait mais monsieur Macron
en 2019 au moment de la vous savez après
la quand il tient la conclusion c'est
long monologue en région là les grands
débats là les réponses rien donné à la
fin c'est ça
oui je les
les cahiers d'oléance terminé la caseou
c'est ça il fait la réponse au gilet
jaune là et puis
euh je sais pas Si vous vous rappelez
euh ça avait été reporté d'une semaine
parce que il y avait eu l'incendie de
Notre Dame. Donc voilà, c'est çait
marqué les esprits à juste titre. Et euh
et donc la première chose qu'il annonce
finalement quand il parle, la première
chose qu'il annonce c'est je vais
supprimer les grands corps. Alors c'est
très bizarre ça. Les grands corps, c'est
ce que je vous ai cité tout à l'heure,
corps des mines, corps des points,
inspection des finances dont il est issu
lui. Enfin, c'est bizarre d'ailleurs
dece qu'un système qu'il a porté lui au
pouvoir peut
il y a pas que lui qui l'a porté, hein.
Oui, oui, oui, bien sûr.
Disons que il doit se dire tiens s'il y
a pas une forme de de
d'auto shaming de sa part de dire c'est
c'est le système va pas très bien
puisquil j'ai pu accéder aux plus hautes
fonctions comme ça. Donc il dit je vais
supprimer les grands corps. Or si vous
voulez il y a pas grand monde qui sait
ce que c'est que les grands corps. Comme
si c'était la réponse au gilets jaunes.
Donc un gilet jaune il sait pas ce que
c'est que les grands corps. Et puis
vous inquiétez pas maintenant il sait.
Oui, d'accord.
Il a compris. Ouais,
il est se passionné.
Oui, oui. Ah oui. Euh et voilà. Donc euh
d'ailleurs, je vais aller plus loin
puisque je suis là-dessus là. Tiens, je
je c'est dans ma la première page de mon
bouquin. Je dis euh bon, c'est plus
facile à lire qu'à dire, mais euh euh
c'est un cas attraper votre bouquin et
lire.
Ah oui, c'est mieux parce que si je le
déforme, c'est pas terrible.
Vous avez besoin de lunettes ?
Non, ça va. Je vous autorise à sortir
vos lunettes.
Ouais, je pas de coqu ici. Euh
euh
profitez pendant que vous cherchez la
page.
Non non, je notre abonnez-vous à notre
YouTube. Euh soutenez-nous sur Tipi, on
a besoin de vous pour continuer et c'est
à vous pour la lecture.
Voilà. B c'est la première page. Que
l'élection de monsieur Macron en 2017
soit une anomalie du système
démocratique de la 5e République est un
problème. Quand je dis une anomalie,
c'est devoir choisir entre lui puis une
forme d'extrémisme et cetera. Enfin bon,
dans un scrutin à deux tours où il y a
plus que deux candidats à la fin. Voilà.
Donc euh donc que l'élection de monsieur
Macron en 2017 soit une anomalie du
système de la 5e République est un
problème, mais n'est pas notre sujet.
que ce ne soit pas une anomalie du
système des grands corps est notre
sujet. J'entends par là, j'entends par
là que
le système des grands corps et
l'inspection des finances avec le
rapport à Macron
en 2007 donc il est rapporteur et
cetera, la possibilité comme ça de se
faire des des relations évidemment il y
a pas que ça. C'est sans doute quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire au point de vue de la
com et la start-up qui l'a fondé pour
prendre le pouvoir. Et c'est aussi le
système des corps et de l'inspection des
finances qui
policier enrièrement.
Henri
Henrièm ?
Ah oui oui. Bah je connais pas
personnellement je de nom bien sûr.
Allez-y continuez.
Euh vous me demandez de parler dans
régulièrement là. Ah bon ? D'accord.
Ouais ouais ouais. Ben donc de voilà,
c'est euh
c'est ben je raconte aussi c'est dans le
bouquin de bon peut-être pas trop
focalisé sur Macron non plus mais c'est
dans le bouquin tout ça était écrit donc
le bouquin de Davelom qui a pas eu le
même succès que pour Hollande s'appelle
le traître et le néant et et ils
interviewent MAC inspecteur des finances
lui aussi ouais Alain Mc
qui qui dit "Ah bah Macron est venu me
voir. Les jeunes ambitieux font tout le
temps la visite du jeune inspecteur des
finances au vieil inspecteur des
finances. Donc il dit c'est bien les
jeunes ambitieux même à au sein de
l'inspection des finances, on parle
d'une frange qui est assez qui est le
subcordine, le subinspection des
finances qui qui comme ça entretient ses
réseaux. Après ça a été la la le rapport
à Tali Macron et cetera. Enfin rapport à
qu'on a appellera bientôt rapport à Tali
Macron. Euh
et puis cette façon aussi de de se
mettre dans le sillage de de gens euh
comme ça qui les adoub un peu plus
anciens comme Hollande euh Main ou
Hollande ben Main euh ça m'a frappé dans
le bouquin d'Avelom et il est beaucoup
euh il conseille énormément Macron y
compris sur des sujets alors moins
maintenant mais à l'époque ouais pour
l'accession au pouvoir beaucoup mais
enfin bon voilà je veux pas non plus
focaliser sur cet exemple-là je
puisqu'on parlait de de d'aspect euh
élector enfin voilà, je voulais vous
dire ça ce ce qui là, cette phrase là
que je vous ai lu, c'est pas une
anomalie du système des grands corps,
quoi. C'est ça qui est c'est ça moi qui
m'a entraîné à écrire en dehors du fait
que mon éditeur m'y a poussé mais et
puis parce que je suis là-dedans depuis
40 ans et donc je vois la petite phrase
que je vous ai dite là, c'est qu'à
stabilité à la direction des grands
groupes. Mais c'est insensé d'entendre
un truc comme ça. Et
d'autant
à la limite comme vous dites si c'était
pour le bien tout mais
s'il y a eu beaucoup de de berésina
j'appelle ça et donc jamais de leçons
tiré de quoi que ce soit. Donc
euh voilà
si ces gens étaient militaires,
ça se terminerait très mal.
Soit il se ferait ravager sur le le
théâtre d'opération,
soit il se ferait ravagé de la deuxème
ligne, il se feraiit remonter jusque au
plus profond de leur tréfond et on
aurait des veuves au pays.
Ouais. Ouais. Mais même si c'était mais
là là comment ça se fait qu'on soit on
les dégage pas, soit ils se fassent pas
secouer, soit ils se tapent pas, je dire
des amendes sur leur salaire s'ils
étaient dans le privé, je parle pas du
privé où il y a des pédalages,
rétroédalage, pantouflage,
rétroantouflage
dans une boîte normale, quelqu'un qui se
vautre comme ça, il se fait mais
expulser Manu Militarie.
Ouais, ben justement pas tellement dans
nos grands groupes français qui sont
tenus par ces grands corps. Je pense que
dans une entreprise américaine ou dans
une entreprise allemande ou même une
entreprise italienne, euh ça se
passerait pas comme ça. En effet, là on
parle de gens qui sont à la tête de ces
grands groupes et qui ont euh euh
c'est une nouvelle noblesse.
Ah bah oui, ça bourdieu. Alors, on peut
lui attribuer ça. Il appelait ça la
noblesse d'État. Ouais. Euh
ça ça s'est mal terminé hein.
Oui oui oui oui oui tout à fait. Oui
absolument. Ça s'est mal terminé.
notamment par exemple au 18e siècle où
la euh
la noblesse est est vraiment euh à
accumuler les privilèges et cetera et
est allé dans le mur quoi. Donc euh je
veux pas je pense pas que enfin je je
sais pas si c'est à l'heure actuelle
mais à l'heure actuelle on vit un
système en France où euh euh ces grands
corps n'ont jamais été aussi puissants.
Donc le président de la République est
inspecteur des finances. Ces trois
premiers ministres successifs sont
conseiller d'état pour Édouard Philippe,
cours des comptes pour Castex, XPON pour
madame Borne. Donc voilà, on est dans un
système qui est Hollande était lui-même
cours des comptes. Enfin bon, voilà.
Donc
est-ce qu'on a les ressources de faire
mieux que parce que on les vilipande, on
les vilipande, on les vilipende mais la
France
telle qu'elle est en ce moment, est-ce
qu'il y a mieux en stock que ça ?
Ah !
Est-ce qu'on on s'est tellement on s'est
pas tellement affaibli ? On s'est
affaibli à un tel point qu'on est obligé
de composer avec ça
et ils le savent et ils s'en mettent un
peu plein les fouilles et ils s'en
mettent un peu plein le réseau, ils s'en
mettent un peu plein ce que vous voulez.
Ouais. Ouais. C'est c'est on entend
souvent là moi dans les discussions,
mais alors qui d'autre que Macron, comme
président de la République et cetera
voilà quels sont les Bah écoutez moi je
suis plutôt d'un naturel optimiste
saintsimolien. Je pense qu'il faut une
refondation complète du de l'éthique de
l'État de de de reprendre faucon. OK. Je
Oui oui oui. Bah oui oui oui. D'accord.
OK.
Mais là là le bateau coule bateau. Il y
a des trous partout. On est bouffé par
les mythes, on se fait attaquer par les
on se fait percuter babor et tribor par
les ors qui a un iceberg devant.
Bon, les gilets jaunes sont en cale et
puis ils sont corvéables à souhait. Euh
en haut, ça bamboche, ça bamboche bien
hein Versailles,
maintenir le vernis social,
ça sa parade avec euh des plein plein
plein de choses. Sauf que quand on fait
le constat de la réalité de de notre
situation, la situation de notre pays,
ça sent le sapin là.
Ça je ça ça sent vraiment le sapin. Les
fondamentaux de soutenabilité de notre
société, ça calange de toute part.
Ça va se terminer comment cette histoire
? On fait quoi ? Il y a qu'à faucon, on
continue à se mettre autour du feu, à
faire vous, à faire des des des
préconisations incantatoires ou des
prédictions incantatoires. On fait quoi
? On n pas dans notre état quelqu'un qui
fait un peu le gendarme en disant
maintenant ça suffit, toi tu dégages,
toi tu dégages et tout ton réseau il
dégage avec.
Il y a pas un président de la République
pour faire ça ?
Ouais ouais. Enfin là, je je là je sors
un peu de mon domaine.
Euh
ouais. Ben disons qu'un système qui a
fonctionné jusqu'en dans les années
euh euh là il il fonctionne plus quoi.
Donc quelles sont les élites
alternatives ? C'est une vraie question.
En tout cas, je pense que celle-là euh
faut qu'elle se remette en question
euh
Fisar.
Ouais. Ouais.
Dard,
moi j'avais une collègue tiens membre du
même corps que moi qui me disait "Oh
mais ça va pas du tout ton fil Twitter,
parfois tu critiques le notre corps des
mines auquel tu'appartient. Tout ça
c'est pas ça la camaraderie et tout.
Tu craches dans la soupe.
Oui par exemple tiens. Ouais. Euh euh
tu craches la main qui te nourrit. Tu ms
tu mors la main qui te nourrit.
Ouais. Et ben je lui ai dit non d'abord
c'est mon boulot de faire ça. Euh
ensuite je lui ai dit mais si on se
remet pas en question nous euh euh
Macron il le fera et puis il nous mettra
dans le mur. J'ai l'habitude de dire que
je
enfin c'est une position qui est pas
facile à tenir parce que est sur la
crête toujours et après on peut tomber
dans un truc où on est plus écouté quoi.
Je défends le corps des mines par
exemple j'appartiens au corps des mines.
défend le corps des mines où ce qu'il
était contre lui-même,
c'est-à-dire ce où ce qu'il est devenu
quoi. Et donc voilà. Alors après, on
peut apparaître comme nostalgique ou un
gars qui est resté bloqué un logiciel
d'avant mais ouais, on peut donner des
exemples quand même de ce que c'était.
Ben, j'ai parlé de George Obes là qui a
été un patron dans le privé aussi qui
venait d'un milieu social très très
modeste qui est devenu patron de Renault
et cetera. euh qui a laissé sa peau
d'ailleurs. Euh voilà. Bon ben qui sont
qui sont ces gens-là de nos jours ? Je
ouais j'en vois pas trop et je vois pas
de d'alternative. Est-ce que ça veut
dire qu'il faut continuer avec ces ces
ces institutions-là ? C'est alors
Macron, il nous a dit on va supprimer
l'ENA. Alors OK. Donc il comme je vous
ai dit, il dit on va supprimer les
grands corps.
C'est le seul truc qu'il dit là. Je
d'ailleurs j'ai donné un rapport à
monsieur Tirier et cetera
et puis après c'est quand les
journalistes lui posent des questions,
dit "Ah Elena, je vais supprimer aussi."
Et puis euh euh ça, j'ai jamais vu ça
dans l'administration quand vous tapez
ww. Donc il crée un institut national du
service public qui va être un gros
bousin, un gros machin encore plus gros
avec un numéro vert.
Oui. Voilà. C'est toujours le le gros
là, c'est comme le classement de
Shanghaiï, on réunit les universités
sans savoir exactement ce que sans
regarder les conséquences que ça peut
avoir quoi. Ça la le mythe de la taille.
Donc on crée l'Institut national du
service public et quand vous tapez quand
même pas mal de gens y compris à
l'étranger qui connaissaient le site
ena.fr www.na.fr
et quand vous tapez ça, vous arrivez à
un message d'erreur. Je sais pas si vous
avez vu les messages d'erreur, c'est des
trucs l'ENAT n'existe plus. Vous pouvez
essayer, j'ai essayé d'essayer encore
hier. L'ENAT n'existe plus. Il faut
taper, il faut refaites dans votre
navigateur insp.fr, un truc comme ça.
C'est-à-dire que c'est là c'est là où va
se nicher la volonté politique. La
volonté politique, elle va se nicher
dans la communication d'un message
d'erreur sur le site ena.fr.
Vous confirmez.
On a une mauvaise connexion internet.
nationale de l'administration
ena.fr
L'école de l'administration ENA a été
supprimée le 31 décembre 2021. Elle a
été remplacée par l'Institut national du
service public
INSP.
Depuis le 1er janvier 2022. Ce site web
n'est donc plus mise à jour.
Mais c'est c'est des messages comme on
voyait dans l'internet il y a 15 ans ça.
Non non mais c'est tout ça pour vous
dire que voilà c'est c'est c'est des
trucs de volonté politique. Le
nom de domaine n'a pas été volé. C'est
pas un
Oui. Voilà. Bah heureusement. Oui. Oui.
Donc voilà. Non mais Lena c'était quand
même connu à l'étranger. Je suis pas en
train de la défendre du tout. Je juste
en train de vous dire qu'on on est en
train de comme partout d'ailleurs à
faire des réformes qui n'ont pas
beaucoup de sens quoi. Donc voilà la
suppression de l'inspection des ce type
de réforme
Ouais.
ou le d'autres réformes c'est pour
l'intérêt du pays ou c'est simplement
pour gagner du temps pour pouvoir
ensuite sauter dans le privé ou aller
faire des conférences à 100000 balles
ailleurs ? C'est quoi ?
On se paye sur la bête, on se paye avec
le carnet d'adresse de la République, on
se vernit avec les ordres de la
République où réellement ça bosse parce
que des cabin ministériel on en a
visité, on a été invité à Ber
numérique.
C'était pas c'était pas sous la prés si
on a eu Moun Majoubi qui nous avait
invité du temps de de Macron mais on a
eu Axel le maire on a été aussi se
balader dans Ber on a même été visiter
le les Liport de Bercy
là où ils ont fait Mission Impossible là
donc c'était la serise sur le gâteau.
Ils ont l'air très fatigués ces gens-là.
Ils sont ils ont l'air très attaqués
mais ils sont très fatigués. Pourquoi ?
Est-ce queils brassent du vent ? sculte
de la fumée où ils bossent réellement où
ils ont l'impression de bosser. Comment
ça se passe ? Ah bah ça ça c'est sûr que
ça tourne en circuit fermé tout ça, je
vous dis entre le Cab, les
administrations, les réponses aux
questions parlementaires.
Mais ce qui ce qui me frappe, c'est que
ouais ce qui peut être un élément de
réponse à votre question, c'est que
avoir l'onction de l'État en France,
c'est super important, quoi. Donc euh ça
la sainte onction,
pardon.
La sainte onction.
Oui, voilà, c'est ça exactement. Oui.
Euh donc euh
je sais pas, je vois pas d'autres pays.
L'Angleterre c'est c'est centralisé mais
pas autant que la France. L'Angleterre
ça ça pas
de Napoléon qu'on a ça.
Ouais. Enfin aussi à cause de l'ancien
régime enfin pas mal à cause de
Napoléon. Oui. qui a structuré bah les
les corps là, le conseil d'État,
l'inspection des finances, c'est fait à
ce moment-là quoi. Donc les corps des
mines, corps des ponts, c'est plus dans
l'ancien régime, c'est les ponts et
chaussées, les mais bon voilà, c'est
c'est
Napoléon. Ouais, on peut dire. Oui. Euh
et bah il y a même le bicentenaire du
corps des mines qui a été fêté en 2010.
Donc ils l'ont attribué à 1810 aussi.
Donc Napoléon. Mais euh
voilà, c'est un pays euh on est un pays
où le le
venir de l'État, c'est vachement
important. Donc euh c'est en ce sens que
euh il y a eu euh bah ces grands corps
euh ils ont cette les membres de ces
grands corps, ils ont l'onction de
l'État pour faire après euh ce qu'ils
veulent dans le privé, euh dans la
politique, dans la parce que
on laissera notre communauté prolonger
avec votre bouquin qui s'appelle comment
déjà ? Technocratisme.
On peut parler de transhumanisme.
Ah ouais, si vous voulez. Ouais. Ouais.
Parce que vous pouvez nous dire
là-dessus comment la société française,
comment nos grands corps quand on voit
Christine Lagarde dire "Oh là là, on va
mettre de l'intelligence artificielle."
Quand on voiton Musk dire le
transhumanisme,
on va quand on voit Laurent Alexandre
nous dire "On va vivre 1000 ans". Quand
on va quand il y en a d'autres qui nous
disent "Oh, la science et la
technologie, ça va nous sauver." Le
technolutionnisme,
le transhumanisme, ça veut dire quoi
pour vous ?
Ouais. Alors, ça c'est mon thème de
recherche, mon précédent thème de
recherche, mais je continue là-dessus
là. Euh moi, j'avais étudié comment euh
dans le 20e siècle en France, il y avait
encore pas mal de discours eugéniste
quoi. Donc Laurent Alexandre, il répète
des trucs euh qu'on trouvait encore dans
les années 30, dans les années 60 sous
la plume de Jean Rostan qui était le
fils d'Edmond Rostan et qui était un
vulgarisateur à la télévision. Donc
voilà là cette notion de surhomme,
d'homme augmenté euh de surhumain de
euh chez le père Tayard de Chardin
d'ultra humain. Voilà donc tout ça c'est
des racines du transhumanisme actuel.
Bon là euh ouais ce qui est plus
inquiétant c'est les les musques et
cetera puisqu'ils sont les c puisque eux
ils ont des moyens d'action assez
importants ils ont énormément d'argent.
Bon après, qu'est-ce que fait la il
diffuse une idéologie transhumaniste au
sens où euh
selon eux, il faut aller vers une
humanité à deux vitesses en quelque
sorte. Donc mais
humanité augmentée.
Ouais. Oui. Oui. Pour eux notamment, il
y a aussi un bouquin moi qui m'a
toujours un peu étonné. Son succès,
c'est Yuval Noah Harari là. Ouais. Homo
sapiens. Bon alors ça se lit bien. Enfin
moi je préfère Jarette Diamond mais ça
se lit bien. Mais euh voilà qu'est-ce
qu'il en reste ? des c'est des
voilà c'est des
pensées très très peu fertile à mon avis
qui
euh
donc voilà ben des des musques, des
ils ont vraiment une une vision de d'une
humanité euh à deux vitesses. Ouais.
Ouais. Voilà, c'est ça. Donc
après faut regarder exactement qu'est-ce
que fait la science en la matière.
Est-ce que
les macaques, ils avaient quand même un
peu mal au crâne avec leur puist. Les
macaques.
Les macaques des lieux de musqu.
Ah ouais. Alors je je sais pas c'est
quoi les macaques des musques là. Il il
les pulsait pour augmenter pour savoir
comment ça se passait.
Bon c'était des macaques en fin de vie
avant. On après lui.
Euh ouais. Bon, je c'est moi je suis
plus sur l'histoire du transhumanisme.
Alors, je vais vous décevoir là mais euh
ouais, je je Bah d'ailleurs, c'est très
curieux d'ailleurs de voir pour relier
les deux sujets. Euh monsieur Macron, il
reçoit, il y a des photos de lui à
Versailles avec Yuval Noarari aussi.
Alors, je je comprends pas très bien. Et
puis on déroule le tapis rouge pour ces
ces grands patrons de la tech. Enfin,
bon, là aussi, il y a Est-ce qu'il y a
pas une matière à retrouver une
souveraineté ? industriel et
technologique sur le sur le sujet de la
de la
bah de la haute technologie de voilà.
Alors après faut se méfier tous les
trucs on va faire en Europe le Google
européen le machin tout ça. Il y a
tellement eu des de de crashing dans le
mur là-dessus déjà que on hésite à
proposer ça. Mais bon euh
Google européen c'était quoi ? C'était
Quant c'est ça ? Bah par exemple, mais
moi j'ai connu autre chose avant,
c'était Cuero. Cuero ça veut dire je
cherche en latin. Moi j'ai connu ça,
c'était du temps de Chiraak. Alors là
qu'est-ce qu'on nous bassinait sur Cuero
?
Alors pourquoi ? Pourquoi
c'était franco-allemand ? Mais c'est
plus scandaleux que Cuero. Quand c'est
bah je sais pas, il y a eu beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent public investis
là-dedans et pour des résultats qui sont
quand même très très
euh pas c'est pas
c'est pas beaucoup.
Ah, je peux pas vous dire là comme ça,
je faut ma documentation là, c'est des
vingtainees de millions d'euros. Enfin
bon, sur des sur des
million d'euros, c'est rien.
Oui. Oui. Enfin, quand c'est de l'argent
public sonant et trébucht, on confond
pas avec la la première levée de fond
qu'ils ont fait chez Axel Springer,
l'allemand.
Ouais. Bon ben donc je vous donne pas de
chiffre parce que je les ai pas en tête
là. Donc, mais voilà, on doit se taper
dans l'administration le moteur de
recherche cointe euh
alors que c'est pas le plus efficace non
plus, quoi. Et compte maintenant, c'est
la caisse des dépôts là. Tiens, on en a
pas parlé avant de la caisse des dépôts.
La caisse des dépôts c'est le bras armé
de il y a beaucoup d'inspecteurs des
finances à la Caisse des dépôts et c'est
eux qui vont investir à la demande de
l'État
à droite à gauche sur des entreprises
pas toujours.
N'état, c'est quoi l'État ? nous ou
c'est l'état ?
Ah bah non, mais c'est l'État dont on
parlait tout à l'heure quoi. Les
ministres, monsieur le maire, monsieur
Macron,
voilà et Coin en est un exemple quoi. Et
puis c'est aussi la Caisse des dépôts,
c'est un truc où vous avez les salaires
du privé sans avoir les risques du
privé. Alors là, c'est un truc bah c'est
dans le privé même chez Min CapG Miniu,
vous pouvez vous faire virer Caisse des
dépôts, vous pouvez pas. C'est pour ça
qu'il y a pas mal de d'inspecteurs. La
banque publique d'investissement, c'est
pareil. Tout ça, c'est j'ai appelé ça
moi dans mon bouquin sur le la
technocratie, le le
pantouflage public, c'est-à-dire on a
tous les avantages du privé pantouflage
et les ceux du public à savoir ne pas
être viré. C'est avoir des gros salaires
en étant sûr de pas être virés. Donc
c'est
c'est votre point de vue ou c'est la
réalité ? Bah ça je pense c'est la
réalité ça c'est voulais caisse des
dépôts. La banque publique
d'investissement c'est c'est
euh voilà c'est alors la banque publique
d'investissement elle fait des trucs
très bien par ailleurs. Et je dis que
dans les carrières de nos membres de
grand corps, elle est enfin voilà, elle
a récupère des gens un peu ce que je
vous disais sur la SNCF là, c'est des
c'est des récupèrent des gens qui
étaient à 50 ans en fin de parcours dans
d'autres entreprises beaucoup plus
challenging et puis qui se retrouvent à
la Caisse des dépôts quoi ou à la banque
publique d'investissement. Donc voilà,
c'est tout. Moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
vraiment les les parcours des de ces
personnes et puis de voir euh et puis
bah tiens quand même si la caisse des
dépôts Ouais. des investissements qui
sont pas toujours euh raisonnés quoi,
hein. Euh je me fais la vocale du diapo
euh euh un moteur de recherche, un data
center, avoir des choses un peu
souveraines, c'est quand même vachement
important pour le business français
européen. Si les Américains nous
décident du jour au lendemain par
rétention parce qu'on les suit pas dans
une x guerre et qu'on est encore les les
méchants français et que ils débaptisent
les frites
au lieu de les appeler les French fries,
c'est les Freedom Fries ou des choses
comme ça, on se retrouve coincé en terme
de business sur internet. Alors, ils
nous ont fait le coup avec les
catapultes de nos de nos portesavion
lors de la Première Guerre en Irak.
On a eu des mesures de rétorsion. Il y
avait des pièces qu'on pouvait pas
changer. Là, on se retrouve avec des des
composants de notre industrie
clé
avec le droit américain dessus. S'ils
sont pas contents, ils nous disent
avoir ce type d'investissement souverain
ou aider le type de de déploiement,
c'est quand même important, non ?
Ouais. Mais regardez, attendez, moi en
2005, j'ai je m'occupais d'un projet qui
s'appelle bibliothèque numérique
européenne qui était censé contrer
Google Books. Bon mais en même temps, je
mouillé dans un projet qui s'appelait
Cuero, je vous disais et là aussi
c'était un moteur de recherche
franco-allemand mais les Allemands, ils
sont retirés parce qu'ils ont vu que ça
rien n'avançait, que il y avait pas
que
voilà, rien n'en sortirait à cause de
l'organisation que ça bureaucratique que
ça avait prise. Alors, c'est marrant que
en 2005 et en 2015, on crée compente
aussi pour les mêmes raisons, quoi.
Donc,
est-ce que il y a pas un problème de
méthode ? Est-ce que si on veut vraiment
avoir un moteur de recherche souverain,
faut pas s'y prendre un peu autrement ?
Voilà, c'est on fait jamais les leçons
de nos échecs, quoi. Donc euh ouais, je
suis d'accord avec vous qu'il faut être
avoir des des clouds souverains, des
moteurs de recherche peut-être
qui soi euh euh qui soit autre chose que
Google. Euh mais comment comment s'en
donner les moyens quoi ça ? que vous
allez me dire il y a qu'à faucon mais
comment s'en donner les moyens quoi. Et
l'Europe elle a très peu impulsé. Euh il
y a beaucoup de discours et peu de
réalisation là-dessus hein. Donc
vous êtes historien des sciences.
Ouais.
Comment vous jugez à l'heure actuelle le
fait qu'il y ait de plus en plus de
créationnistes dans les écoles ou du
moins des élèves
euh ayant une vue créationniste de de la
chose ? Comment vous percevez la
défiance
d'une certaine partie de l'opinion
publique envers la science ? Comment
vous l'expliquez ? Est-ce que les
scientifiques ou les ministres ont des
choses à se reprocher ou est-ce que on a
laissé tellement tomber notre système
éducatif
que maintenant
voilà dans tout ce que vous dites, je
dirais oui à tout. C'est-à-dire que euh
c'est marrant, vous rejoignez un autre
sujet de recherche que j'avais que j'ai
appelé Alter Science. Moi, j'ai pas mal
étudié le créationnisme
euh avec euh
des types qui avaient je rend hommage à
un philosophe comme Dominique Lecour, il
avait fait vraiment le étudier le
créationnisme enfin en tout cas dans le
monde français dès la fin du 20e siècle.
Bah moi, je vais vous dire tiens
là-dessus un bon exemple, c'est ce qui
s'est passé avec le Covid. Moi, j'ai
arrêté. C'est-à-dire, c'est à ce
moment-là, les scientifiques ont fait de
la politique.
On peut reprocher. Enfin, le podi s'est
imix s'est imissé dans la science, a
voulu se parer d'une légitimité
scientifique. Mais inversement, on peut
peut considérer que le le parler du
conseil du comité scientifique, je sais
plus comment ça s'appelait, a voulu
faire une
défense, non ? Euh non non, là je parle
du comité scientifique euh pardonner le
nom de son président mais euh
euh a voulu faire de la politique aussi
d'une certaine manière quoi. Donc on a
tellement mélangé enfin je sais pas, je
trouve que le Covid a a vraiment euh
cassé les lignes entre sciences et
politique à un point euh important qui
est dont il est difficile de se relever
je trouve. Donc après, on peut dire
"Ouais, c'est le système éducatif, c'est
on diffuse pas, c'est la connaissance.
C'est peut-être pas les bonnes personnes
qui diffusent la connaissance et c'est
peut-être pas les bonnes personnes qui
l'ouvrent.
Oui. Oui.
Parce que là l'histoire, la moitié a été
désavouée et l'autre moitié a été absus.
Euh quelle moitié alors ? Pardon ?
Bah et quand quand on entendait dire
"Attention les pharmaciens, si vous
vendez des masques, c'est 10000 €
d'amende et puis de toute façon les
masques, ça sert à rien."
Ah oui ? Ça c'était terrible quoi de de
dire les masques, ça sert à rien.
C'était alors qu'ils en savaient rien
quoi. C'était
Mais non, c'est pas qu'ils s'en savaient
rien.
Non mais il au moment où il le disait,
ils avaient plus de masque. Ils avaient
la gestion de de logistique de nos
grands corps.
Mais c'est de la funistie.
Oui,
c'est de la funisterie. Moi, j'avais une
sœur qui a un labo d'analyse médicale.
Elle pleurait, elle pleurait le soir
tellement parce que tapait tous les
examens que les hôpitaux faisaient plus.
Et puis le soir, elle devait aller
chercher chez des amis employés chinois
des masques pour son personnel quoi.
Donc tellement elle était crevée quoi.
Donc oui, oui, c'est je parle d'avril
2020 là. Donc
oui oui, ça a été une et puis non mais
ce qui a je me rappelle la porte-parole
du gouvernement là, je sais plus comment
elle s'appelait la
CBend.
Voilà, c'est ça.
Qui assume mentir pour couvrir le
président. C'est terrible ça. Terrible
mentir en utilisant la science,
c'est-à-dire de dire "On n'est pas sûr
que les masques les masques servent à
rien en fait." Et ça c'est des trucs qui
euh
bon voilà. Euh est-ce qu'elle savait
qu'il servait à quelque chose ? Est-ce
que c'est parce que il y en avait pas
qu'elle disait ça ? Enfin, c'est tout
ça, ça a été vraiment
quand le médecin journaliste
s'exprime sur un plateau télé au tout
départ de la pandémie
et qu'il ne parle pas de du côté
aéroporté ou de de la potentialité du
côté aéroporté, du côté manué, de la
rémanence sur les surfaces et que on a
une correspondance directe one parl de
G. C'est quoi ? C'est un mauvais
journaliste, c'est un mauvais médecin,
c'est la charte de Munique qui est pas
respectée, c'est le serment d'Hippocrate
qui est pas respecté, c'est un
scientifique, c'est un journaliste,
c'est un mélange des genres ou c'est
simplement un petit télégraphiste ?
Ouais, je dirais peut-être pas un petit
télégraphiste, mais c'est quelqu'un qui
veut se mettre en valeur euh sur les
ondes, quoi. C'est ça le problème, c'est
que euh voilà, on est dans une époque où
euh euh
on se met en valeur sur certaines ondes
les plus euh réputées euh
et puis euh on raconte beaucoup de
bêtises, quoi. Donc, et c'est vrai pour
le Covid comme pour d'autres choses,
hein. C'est vrai pour le transhumaniste,
c'est vrai pour pas mal de trucs quoi.
Comment on fait pour combattre la
défiance qu'il y a maintenant vers la
science ? On fait quoi ? On continue
d'insulter les gens qui sont défiants,
les traitants de tous les noms, de
débiles modes débiles, de plat du front,
de conspirationniste,
de machin. On continue de leur cracher
dessus en les motivant à devenir encore
plus des démons.
Ça ça fonctionne, ça fonctionne pas ou
on essaie d'être bienveillant, d'avoir
un mé à coule pas, de se dire voilà, on
s'est peut-être mal exprimé, on était
peut-être perdu.
On sait peut-être comment on fait pour
resp
Oui, ben la réponse est la deuxième.
Bien sûr, moi j'ai toujours plaidé que
euh de dire on retourne au Moyen-Âge,
enfin ce genre d'argument, c'est c'est
ce qui est complètement débile de dire
ça parce que parce que les gens auquell
vous faites allusion, ils ont aussi des
raisonnements. Donc voilà, je pense que
est-ce qu'ils ont les qualifications ?
Parce que quand même
raisonner ça demande pas forcément des
qualifications. Raisonner
raisonner avoir sa sa propre logique
demande pas forcément des
qualifications.
J'accepte quand on file du pognon à ces
gens-là du pognon public
qu'il y a pas de remise en question sur
l'aspect délétaire de la chose
comment on fait on continue leur fil du
pogon parce qu'il y a que eux sur le
pavé.
la psyché des gens quand il y a une
défiance en terme de science ou en terme
de religion face à la science,
on fait quoi ? On continue d'avoir des
créationnistes partout, de penser qu'il
y a des gens qui ont visité la lune avec
un chevalé ? On fait quoi ?
Oui, c'est c'est de bah moi, j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur les
créationnismes. Alors, je déjà
comprendre les arguments aussi, c'est
c'est super important. Enfin, je veux
dire ne de ne pas les considérer comme
des je vous dis c'est ne pas les
considérer comme des h
des arriérés. Ouais. C'est ça c'est
c'est très pénible quoi de de vraiment
de
de critiquer,
on va dire le camp adverse avec ce genre
d'argument quoi. Donc euh
c'est pas de la critique, c'est c'est de
la
Oui, c'est de la calomnie. Oui, oui,
oui, oui, oui. C'est de la Oui, oui,
oui, je suis d'accord. Ouais.
La chasse aux sorcières du 21e siècle.
Oui. Oui. On peut pas prendre des
expressions eux, c'est de l'arrogance
pour reprendre. Euh donc euh euh voilà,
faut
bah travailler, essayer de comprendre
les arguments en question et puis euh
après avoir des gens euh qui
savent expliquer qui
euh
est-ce que on ira vers moins de
créationniste, je sais pasin
euh
pareil nos politiques il disent on n
plus autant des amiches et cetera. et ça
veut rien dire de dire ça. Enfin, c'est
c'est des arguments qui sont
complètement qui sont complètement euh
bah voilà, faut pas critiquer les gens
qui sont d'un avis différent de vous sur
ces ces sujets là, les traitants d'Amich
ou enfin vous je sais pas si vous vous
rappelez là
en les traitants d'Amiches quoi. Ça
c'est a euh ils sont bien fendus la
gueule he d'ailleurs ou quand des
problèmes énergétiques, ils vont ils
vont c'est un peu comme les nord-coréens
non ? Ah oui oui oui. Euh donc voilà euh
je peux vous couper ?
Ouais.
Question internet. Comment se porte
l'ordre mes lien ? Mais ça c'est
l'ordre quoi ?
L'ordre mé lien mais c'est une c'est un
private joke. C'est une vanne privée.
Euh deuxème question. Nos dirigeants
pichent que d à la science et la
technique
mythe ou réalité.
Est-ce que nos dirigeants pas rien
à la science et à la technologie et la
technique pardon ? Est-ce qu'on en fait
pas trop sur l'intelligence artificielle
en ce moment ? Et il cite de Gaulle, je
demande à vérifier la citation de de
Gaulle. De Gaulle de points en France
sans état sa merde.
Fermez les guillemets.
Vous choisissez une des trois ou des tr
Ouais. Ouais. Euh bah par exemple, je
sais pas euh les les ce que nos
dirigeants un truc que je voulais vous
dire, c'est par exemple moi j'avais
écouté madame Merkel qui est une
ancienne chimiste parler du Covid à la
télé, c'était c'était tout à fait
étonnant quoi. C'était de c'était de
manière beaucoup plus didactique,
pédagogique. Je parle de madame Anguela
Merkel qui était chancelière à l'époque
quoi, de manière beaucoup plus
didactique que
monsieur Macron.
Prof. Non.
Merel, elle était prof. Non
non, non seulement elle était prof, mais
elle était chimiste. Elle est une sorte
d'agrégé de chimie, hein. Donc elle
connaît bien la science hein. Donc
voilà, je je dis pas que les les
scientifiques sont les mieux faits pour
être des politiques, mais toujours
est-il que dans ce cadre là, elle avait
bon et puis elle était plus populaire,
faut bien dire ce qui est.
H ouais, je me rappelle plus les autres
trucs. Pardon ce que je voulais euh
de Goule, c'est la mer ça merdois en
France sans état ça merdois.
Ouais bah écoutez oui de Gaulle c'était
ça c'est sûr queil y avait une vision de
l'État
chez de Gaulle qui était très
un sens de l'état qui était qui était
important hein. Donc
ça sur sa facture d'électricité
d'ailleurs.
Oui oui oui. Et puis
voilà, c'était pas
c'était pas
cette
usine à faire des
des membres de grands corps qui sont en
cabinet ministériel à 28 ans et cetera
et puis qui partent en entreprise quoi.
C'était autre chose. Trivialement, ça
donne quoi ? Un peu plus résumé
trivialement et un peu plus
vulgairement, ça donne quoi ?
Est-ce qu'on a pas une usine à PQ en
fait ?
Est-ce que on n pas Non mais faut
appeler un chat un chat.
Parce que quand je vois qu'ils sont pas
capables d'anticiper la guerre, quand je
vois qu'ils sont pas capables, ils
agitent les bras comme des comme des
poulets sans tête à faire leur sanction
hyper rapidement alors que ça a pas été
anticipé en terme économique, ça a rien
été anticipé. On les voit.
Oui. Puis l'énergie par exemple, on
arrête son mais on reprend le le les
RNR. Voilà.
En français, on a un mot, c'est des on a
des usines à peine cul
parce que c'est très bien de faire c'est
très bien de faire des cours bêtes. Oh,
c'est très bien monsieur le ministre.
C'est très bien d'aller dans les sing
pour pouvoir échanger sa petite carte de
visite, bien se faire voir pour espérer
un poste. C'est très bien quand on voit
les les Vous avez jamais vous avez
jamais été un colloque du K d'orsais.
Ça vaut son besoin de cacahuète.
Je vous jure quand on voit les petits
jeunes essayer d'aller faire un petit
peu, on va dire de de l'approche
gentille avec des yeux de châon pour
dire là j'ai besoin d'un stage.
Infiné, ça fait quoi ça ?
L'aspect patriotique de la chose, elle
est où ? Là, c'est un peu chacun son
cuidu pour tous,
non ?
Oui. Oui. Oui. Bah euh ouais, c'est
c'est à un moment ça s'est dégradé. On
on parlait là du conseiller industriel
de Pompidou, Bernardbert. Il y avait une
vision euh à l'époque euh
euh même dans les mémoires tiens les
mémoires de monsieur Mono qui était un
délégué à l'aménagement du territoire
sous Giscar et il dit "Ça m'a étonné, le
président de la République m'a dit "Non
mais vous n'y pensez pas. un
investissement catari dans cette ce
secteur industriel, c'est c'est
n'importe quoi. Et donc Giscar à
l'époque
c'est dans les mémoires de Jacques Monau
qui était vraiment pardon de Jérôme Mono
qui était
un un membre de la cour des comptes euh
et délégal àement du territoire qui a
porté un projet clé en main et Giscard
n'en a pas voulu pour des raisons de
souveraineté notamment. Donc si vous
voulez, il y avait une vision qui était
euh c'est vous qui c'est votre lecteur,
c'est votre internaute qui cite De
Gaulle. On peut prolonger un peu comme
ça de Gaulle euh Pompidou. Euh mais
l'État Ouais ouais l'État euh
a son importance en France. Je le disais
tout à l'heure. Ouais.
Fac check. Grille des salaires de la
Caisse des dépôts en février 2021.
Administrateur général.
Échelon maximum H3
traitement brut mensuel 5993,42
centimes par mois.
H
le lien c'est cdc.uncasa.org
grit de traitement de
Ouais.
Bon
conseil scientifique Jean-François
Delfing. Oui, le nom que j'ai en tête.
Bien sûr.
Quel est votre point de vue sur la
militarisation de l'espace ?
Euh al je fa vous dire joker hein parce
que c'est
pas vraiment mon domaine
euh
bah la militarisation de beaucoup de
choses hein de la sécurité
interne aussi. Enfin je trouve que dans
un un monde qui devient de plus en plus
surveillé aussi. Alors, depuis l'espace,
je sais pas, mais euh dans la rue de
plus en plus et via internet de plus en
plus. Donc euh tout ça va ensemble. Je
c'est un peu une généralité que je vous
dis là, mais euh
c'est
alors je vais rebondir sur votre domaine
de votre secteur activité et ensuite je
vais vous demander quelques bouquins.
On a eu la chance de connaître le
fondateur du programme spatial français.
Oui, c'est Blamon.
Jacques Blamont.
Et un jour, on avait une grande
discussion parce que on avait à peu près
le même constat que vous et il me dit
Sky, c'est mon surnom.
Hm hm.
Tu sais, j'ai vous savez, j'ai mis 18
ans à pouvoir envoyer des ballons sur
Vénus parce que un jour, j'avais fait un
rêve
et je voyais des ballons sur Vénus. Ça
m'a pris 18 ans et le meilleur conseil
qui m'a laissé, c'est il faut apprendre
à composer avec les cons.
Est-ce que là en ce moment en France
entre les grands selon vous les grands
corps défaillant nos administration mal
géré un arrivisme chronique du
pantouflage rétantouflage
chronique ? Est-ce qu'on n'est pas
entouré
de connards ?
Bah je sais pas quelle analogie on peut
faire avec l'espace et Jacques Blont là,
mais
ces gens-là sont pas censés être des
connards puisqu'ils sont recrutés.
Donc oui, donc ça serait vraiment euh
malheureux
si c'est le cas. Oui.
Ouais. Oui, des gens qui parfois
euh ont pu penser qu'à leurs propres
intérêts. Ouais, à ce moment-là, on peut
les qualifier ainsi, quoi. Donc euh
Mais alors, qui compose avec qui là ?
Qui sont les autres qui qui sont qui
sont les blamons ? Qui sont les
euh je sais pas, j'ai pas en tête là,
mais il y a 15 jours, j'ai appris qui
est-ce qui était le un polytechnicien
Béteil qui fait le programme
aérospatial,
aéronautique, on va dire français, qui
fait l'ERBUS en fait hein. Donc c'est
Galois qui avait lâché ce nom-là. C'est
marrant, c'est rare de d'entendre des
noms comme ça de gens qui des ingénieurs
de terrain qui auquels on rend hommage
et Blamon en fait partie d'ailleurs. Euh
donc voilà, mais qui sont les Blamons,
les béteilles euh de nos jours sur des
programmes comme ça, sur de
l'informatique,
c'est euh monsieur Niel ?
Je sais pas, je
m'a pas semblé que c'était le cas quoi.
Donc
est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins
conseiller notre communauté mis à part
le vôtre ? Vous avez le droit de le
montrer une fois d'ailleurs à la caméra
?
Ah c'est autorisé.
Ouais mais
pas plus du tout.
Voilà. Il est bleu blanc rouge.
Tu me fais un zoom sur la caméra ? On
arrête de bouger.
Ouais
tu me le zoomes un peu. Montre montre à
notre communauté qu'on a réussi à avoir
un objectif qui zoome proprement.
Tu me fais un beau point.
Oubliez pas de nous nous soutenir sur
Tipi.
Vous pouvez relâcher votre main droite.
D'accord.
Trois bouquins conseillers à notre
communauté.
Ah bah alors euh
bah moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié un livre
euh je vous l'ai cité plusieurs fois là.
Esra Souleiman 1970
18.
Euh, j'ai plus le titre en français,
c'est en en anglais, c'est The French,
the politics of survival. En français,
euh les élites en France, ça doit
s'appeler un truc comme ça. Souleiman su
S su
voilà, les élites en France. On parlait
de créationnisme. Moi, j'ai
euh
Vous avez un ami imaginaire ? Vous
croyez en Dieu ?
Disons que je suis agnostique. Oui, je
pose des questions. Ouais. Ouais.
Pourquoi ?
C'est la question qu'on pose. Vous
gagnez combien ?
Je gagne 5000 netes.
Euh
donc un deuxème livre.
Un deuxème livre, bah je euh
bah Dominique le cour humain
post-humain, tiens sur le
transhumanisme, c'est un un très bon
livre au puf.
Euh
ben je sais pas, un troisème livre, je
vous citerai un truc qui n'a
strictement rien à voir. Par exemple,
les mémoires d'outreetombes de Château
Brillant, c'est pour moi c'est le neck
plus ultra.
Magnifique.
Ouais.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à la
mer.
Ouais, je sais pas. C'est chacun
dans son jeune âge doit enfin dans son
jeune âge à partir de 10 ans doit
essayer de
s'intéresser de bon c'est difficile
pas forcément être bon à l'école quoi,
mais de garder des centres d'intérêt
d'avoir des des trucs qui creusent quoi
sur lequels il il se voit comme pas il
se voit pas qu'il se représente Mais il
il fait un travail, on va dire de
recherche à 10 ans, ouais, je sais pas,
quelque chose qui qui creuse, qui sache
creuser quoi, qui ça peut être de la
musique, ça peut être l'informatique, ça
peut être
euh euh
Ouais, c'est ça. d'avoir des
passions euh
dans le domaine de la connaissance.
Ouais. Voilà. Ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas jouer par ailleurs, quoi. Non,
mais je veux dire voilà ce ce conseil
que vous me demandez à des jeunes, je le
formulerai comme ça.
Alexandre Mati, merci.
Merci
à vous.
[Musique]